on va jouer à touche pas à mon secret on
va le vois plus mon secret c'est parti
tout choix moi je comprends rien au
jingle ce soit n'importe quoi alors on
me dit dans l'oreillette que quelqu'un
nous a laissé un message à à écouter ici
la voix serrée la de nombreuses très
concernant l'équipe sont restés trop
longtemps caché ce soir tu as la
possibilité de découvrir si tu veux en
savoir plus il suffit de le demander
1 voix c'est tout pour le moment les
gars la voie sera tête de ma mère est
peu disert n'importe quoi tu es comme sa
voix la voix a dit moi juste tu art
arrivé tuée j'aurais deux baguettes bien
cuites ici la voix la voix voudrait deux
baguettes bien cuites
[Rires]
ce pelé mais moi genre tu rentres chez
toi
la voile rothschild avec la fée shelly
cv ou homo ce quoi ce soir à vis ici la
voix
jiri qu'est ce qu'on mange ce soir je
veux mettre mes mois et un dernier truc
qui me met une dernière à cela parce que
moi j'imagine si la voix c'est mon
europe et il a reçu le bulletin
voilà mon frère il me bat ici là moi on
a reçu ton bulletin vertus dessus dans
le salon et tu peux rajouter yarki coach
l'a opéré dit c'est ça ici la voix on a
refait son retard et à tout de suite
dans le salon a requis quatre là ici la
voix
on a reçu tant bulletin vient maintenant
dans le salon et après tu sors c'est
tout pour le moment il est resté serré
la paloise à ce que la voix et par
derrière déclaré karzaï alors donc vous
avez vous avez donc des secrets n'est
secret mecheri ici alors est ce qu'on
peut avoir les secrets qui s'affiche et
je vais essayer de trouver quels sont
vos secrets ici merci agathe henry alors
je suis la meilleure amie ou le d'un
président de la république
ici il ya le ou la meilleure amie d'un
président de la république ne seraient
pas au courant
alors on serait pas au courant alors
franchement daniel peut-être de giscard
neurones économie alors forcément c'est
forcément un journaliste alors on peut
avoir on peut avoir quand même peut-être
un indice avec la voix ou quelque chose
la voix un avis personnel un à dix on
peut la voir la 10 c'est un homme
d'accord est-ce qu est-ce qu est-ce que
c'est jean-michel série comme il a été
grand reporter et tous deux clament
secret bien gardé je ne connaîtrais même
pas aux seuls faits par le cim guinea
c'est vous c'est moi journaliste c'est
sérieux ah oui ah oui mais fait pas
français le voient c'est vous tous mais
c'est moi ou cette présidente vous êtes
président ira me that à midan président
lors du breil genre jouer à président de
la république du libéria donc tu es
amené avec lui et la seule photo que tu
as trouvé si tu passes derrière dieter
tu te fous de ma gueule ou quoi
dis moi c'est le jour de son transfert
de p g 1 milles en 1995 à cannes
en effet les deux seuls journalistes
présents oui mais j'ai dit oui mais là
c'était quand il était joueur de foot
oui j'étais très content parce qu'eric
doigt quand il était joueur de tennis
wii et une fois qu'il était chanteur
renaud cartier à se contenir ses plumes
on s'aime beaucoup suivi ces campagnes
présidentielles avait été libéré à le
voir j'ai été au liberia le voir alors
quand il était joueur quand il venait
d'arrêter sa carrière
est-ce que là vous avez des nouvelles de
lui la grenouille je suis en train d'en
prendre et je n'exclus madray remet au
sud
rencontrer très bientôt mais faire moi
aussi je peux aller sur un style le
suivre c'est de la merde soit 20 morts
non mais non partant je suis ami de bibi
au ghana par exemple je m'en vante pas
chanter tout versement mais je dis pas
de meilleur ami j'aime rendre pas comme
ça les cds qui fait d elle est décédée
imbibé d db6 et vous ressortez mais vous
sortez tout doucement suis là une bonne
émission mais il va se rafraîchir qu'est
ce qui se passe jean-michel non je me
demande si elle est sûre je sais pas non
un côté on va vérifier elle est passée
les passagers c'est à dire oui oui c'est
pour ça que le monde a apprécié ses
ventes puisse contredire tout ce dont
j'ai un doute mais oui
sa mère benjamin chômage à dormir
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la menace est réelle mais vous allez on
embrasse sa famille de bibi on abbas
tout le monde franchement vous êtes
vraiment des relevés vous vous sortez
[Applaudissements]
musique c'est pas les buts où on apporte
quoi aller deuxième secret deuxième
secret qui va s'infliger sur les j'ai
été très très proche de tom cruise
non mais là il a été très proche de tom
chose moi on se calme mais ce coup là
c'est maman qui opère alors oui est ce
que c'est une fille ou un garçon la voix
bonne question
c'est une fille c'est daniel way quoi
daniel première innocente comme vous et
moi dans les rues daniel tahiti c'est
toi qui étais proche de damas comme si
vous faisiez célèbre attend que tom
cruise mais je devrais te le vrai mais
pour moi ça faisait partie d'une mission
de mission impossible
gta j'étais journaliste découvert
plusieurs festivals de cannes pourrait
donc j'ai passé un bon moment dans sa
dans sa chambre avec tout ça c'est bien
bien passée et il reste d'ailleurs un
souvenir une photo qui va tous retrouvés
voilà et au toit
[Rires]
tél
ouais bon côté a tant fait alors je vais
tenir
je leur ai dit on voit vous êtes très
proche des gens les gens qui l'ont
regardé en direct et qui connaissent un
peu les relations humaines voit tout de
suite que ça c'est quelque part elle
saura tom cruise il est celle où la
voici ce que ce n'est pas une photo
montage
la bonne c'est une photo montage aussi
mal fait
c'est vraiment vous êtes coupé cammas
j'ai une brain et d'autres mots coeur du
coup je pensais même que c'était pour
moi 92 j'avais 18 ans j'étais à new york
que j'étais tout seul pour apprendre
l'anglais je m'ennuyais
j'ai arrêté une avant-première et mais
tous les journalistes et j'étais le seul
gamin comme ça qui me tenait tout le
monde criait tomtom il est tout petit
enfin m 68 c1 comme les tomtom dom tom
il s'est arrêté auprès de personnes
étudiées avec tom pouce non on
s'arrêtait que pour une personne ce
petit garçon qui a vu juste un polaroïd
c'est moi il m'a serré la main il m'a
dit qu'est ce que tu veux et je dis je
rêverais sur votre métier et m'a dit tu
le feras un jour web heilige connerie
n'est pas anglais je jure que c'est vrai
jure que c'est vrai il est protégé mais
pas de merci merci et s'il vous plaît
qu'aux troisième secret qu'un troisième
secret regardez j'ai joué le rôle
principal d'une comédie musicale alors
c'est quelqu'un qui chante bien mais
c'est vous alors à cassis ici arrêtez de
me faire chier avec ça bah ça va vous
êtes chanteur vous quand vous chantez 7
entre eux en premier degré quand même
valérie basso pas maxime guinea valérie
bénaïm tu vois valérie bénaïm véronique
hockey balle et l'aimer mais de nous
convier tap tap tap amap les comédies
musicales ces fonds des chansons surtout
tu vas genre aller et elle va les
chercher ben avant d'aller me chercher
tap tap tap à ma porte
c'est pamela bach avec ce pays ici la
voix ou est ce que tu veux un indice oui
merci oui alors celui qui porte ce
secret est avec les filles
ce que l'on appelle un marc marquez
hashtag sur twitter enfin maxime dans
une comédie musicale qui s'appelaient
alice au pays des merveilles
c'est l'histoire d'alice au pays des
merveilles mais dans le domaine des
drogues c'est un spectacle de prévention
j'avais deux rôles le rôle du leader
beau gosse et signer chaîne alors vous
aviez le rôle du leader bogosse et du
championnat tellement qu'elle vous
faisiez le mieux non ça c'est quoi le
shopping j'hallucine faysal années 2000
est là surtout la question du coup c'est
à quoi ressemblaient les autres qui
étaient moins beau et maxime est très
beau la via veneto maxi je pense que tom
cruise
il vous aurait dit vous auriez fait
encore une plus grande carrière tu dois
vous me trouvez - book machine gainey
mais ouais ouais garde m'en vais
raconter leur attelage déjà
allez marseille c'est mon prochain
secret calmez vous allez de la et
thénardier dans ce cas là c'est bon oui
je suis un ou une sorcière sorcier ou
une sorcière
fais toi sur sa bien aimée non non non
non valérie bénaïm non est ce qu'on peut
avoir un avis sur celui que celui qui
porte ce secret a une passion pour les
choses anciennes
c'est ce à quoi
non en fait en fait c'est ça c'est vous
de voir ça oui enfin le l'intitulé est
un peu un peu gros mais comme dans ces
quatre bateaux dont il est dit ce que tu
as un mec dans un cercueil mon secret je
suis mort oui alors donc donc qu'il ya à
peu près 10 ans enfin non quand j'avais
à peu près huit ans je mettais des
pétales de fleurs dans des fioles et
tout ça en fait j'essaye de faire des
philtres d'amour donc je faisais ma
serre et tout ça et tout et j'avais dit
à mes copines comme quoi se sentait
super bon que j'avais réussi à faire des
parfums des filtres et tout est en gros
elles m'ont volé le brevet et elles ont
elles ont fait la même chose et elle
sont allés vendre ça à l'entourage et
elles se sont fait je suis pas moins 50
euros dans le temps c'était énorme
mais au fond on est sûr cierge à un
philtre d'amour d'amour non mais au-delà
de ça j'ai fait plein de stage non mais
cyril c'est vrai le pendule le pendule
trouver de l'eau chercher les zorra et
tout et tout la dernière fois la jauge
était en vacances elle m'a donné le
numéro de ma chambre
elle le connaît ce mystère en plus à
distance non elle a d une sorcière boily
nymphomane
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais d'alfie cm joue sur ce raid est
jamais venu au rassemblement elle m'a
dit je sais ça m'a étonné sur la tête de
ma mère
ben ouais j'ai des connexions quoi jeu
j'aime bien c'est une bonne qualité
filtres pour terminer un crochet par
contre elle a aurait terminé avec vous
serez était allé dernier deux derniers
secrets allez on y va on a un dernier
secret
merci j'ai un rapport particulier avec
le nombre 188 jean-michel le nombre de
conquêtes amoureuses nom de médias la
voix est ce qu'on peut avant elle a dit
oui cyril voici l'un disent bonjour vous
êtes bien se répondre
la bagarre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a fêté par ses rôles où aller cher au
loup